but I don't think flirting it with what
it is is cheating that's emotional
cheating right there can someone give me
a definition of flirting someone give
[Music]
me give
it
let's go can we start that again cut you
don't get to say cut dude you're not the
director
I genuinely thought I would find love on
Bachelor in Paradise
I was I mean I was definitely in but it
was just like there's also that level of
pessimism like it's tough you know it's
like there's a whole bunch of people
there yeah you know they might not be
interested in you and so it was kind of
like I was hopeful but I don't know if I
was like 100 certain that I was gonna
find love you know yeah because you
can't be 100 certain of anything right
no you really can I mean you could
strongly agree or some would agree but I
had went there just watching a season or
two like I Googled some marriages that
they were like actually together so I
was like damn like these people are
married three four plus years like it's
pretty legit so yeah I kind of thought
like hey nothing else is working so why
not this I hate that you're so far away
but you know yeah
there we go yeah I would move for a
relationship if my partner wasn't local
oh yeah
why is everyone looking at him oh man
dang man it all depends where a little
selfish over there bro I never did it
before and it didn't work out so I don't
think I'll do it again they gotta come
to me now love is like something that
doesn't come around all that often no
that's true and when you do find it like
for me it's like hey Brady got something
yeah
I could like when you find the right
person you could be in the
crappiest area in the world bro and it
could still be freaking you know Heaven
that's so true home is where almost
where the heart is I was in a long
distance relationship and I feel like it
didn't work because we weren't together
like you know the communication
obviously you can have that but you know
ideally you would want that you don't
want that to be a barrier I definitely
would move but I'm a little biased
because I fly for free so wherever I
need to go I can just jump on a plane so
like kind of what Braden says you know
it doesn't come around often so if it's
there snatch it run with it baby unless
I'm gonna agree with what you guys are
saying
somewhat my experience on Bachelorette
changed my approach to Bachelor in
Paradise
are you guys not confident Who You Are
well for me for me on The Bachelorette I
didn't get to talk to Michelle to the
third row ceremony so I feel like I was
just sitting back and being a guy in the
background so that's why I came down on
the beach gun blazing with main
character Vibes yeah my Approach leading
to The Bachelorette was
um kind of like what will saying like I
had no idea how the cameras worked you
know apparently apparently you uh faced
the camera night one yeah checked my
hair three times I had no idea how the
production side work I had no idea like
that you had to ask to talk to her that
you'd asked to talk to people so like my
experience on The Bachelorette as most
people know was cut very very short and
was pretty much non-existent so I said
you know what I'm gonna let my hair down
on the beach and just kind of like be
myself and people like me great if they
don't you know see ya so yeah I'm a
pilot I'm gonna wear the uniform and
rock the aviators and I'm gonna fly
around baby so like that's kind of how I
played it yeah I hear that it seemed
like less of a competition for sure
that's how I felt all the bachelorette a
little bit I mean I don't know it was
just like you're like how are you going
to get time tonight you know it's like
I'm gonna do this I'm gonna do that that
but on the beach man it's like yo that's
like this is like my wheelhouse now you
get to talk to multiple people whenever
you want you know lettuce wrap whenever
you want you know come back the format
seemed a little different from like what
I came from from The Bachelorette yeah I
had fun on Paradise I'll move yeah yeah
I didn't want to give them it but I'll
give him when it came to Bachelor in
Paradise I think I was uh I allowed
myself to lean more into the experience
just because again it felt more natural
it's definitely I think I allowed myself
to be more vulnerable in this one for
sure yeah
flirting isn't
thank you
prove me wrong
um
I think that it comes to the intention
behind it flirting in general is just
making someone feel good it's joking
it's bannering it's all that stuff and
so like you do that you can flirt with a
guy you can flirt with a girl it doesn't
mean you're trying your intention is to
hook up with them is to sleep with them
is to start a relationship with them if
the person I'm with is saying is
cheating then again like you can
reconsider from there but I don't think
flirting out with what it is is cheating
today I have the most opposing views
with Braden you know he just sees Things
From a Different Light and I respect it
too because uh he brings up a lot of
valid points but the flirting thing
that's very traumatic for me personally
like if I'm in a setting and the person
I'm dating is you know off flirting to
the side and I'm just like I feel
disrespected Ray would you be cool if
your chick passed a note to some some
dude what'd it say on it yeah probably
something flirty that's different like
so perfect example your girlfriend sees
a dude with a nice pair of shoes I
really love your shoes that's flirting
that's not funny I don't think that's
fine can someone give me a definition
this is weird to behave as though
attracted to or trying to attract
someone but for amusement
that's a that's emotional cheating right
there yeah I just wouldn't want the
energy that my person's given to me to
be given to somebody else I mean I don't
want to play semantics here but the
question is is flirting cheating nothing
in that definition says it's cheating if
you're trying to attract for amusement
it's not for the intention of being with
that person it's the intention behind
the ACT that's what it comes down to so
if your intention is just to be kind to
her then it's not flirting correct I
agree with you but you know you're a
genuine but if you're like Whispering
like her ear and stuff and like you know
like there's also levels to it there's
levels to everything and I'm just saying
like flirting at its basic of what
flirting is is not bad I'm gonna go one
more this way really
oh
I use that you're gonna stand on that
ledge I mean again I don't I don't
strongly agree with it because again
we can agree to disagree we're going to
agree to disagree I'm just saying bro I
would be okay with an open relationship
y'all really trying to make me sweat
hell no no my person no my person no
the open relationship one that was a
question that was kind of like out there
because this is what Paradise is all
about it feels like we're in a huge open
relationship the whole time I definitely
wouldn't let that fly in the real world
do you know anyone that's been an open
relationship I do yes I do did it work
no no it's toxic are they happy I I have
met some people that have been happy
with it like uh they have the
perspective that like a relationship's
not ownership I mean for me uh I think
that I have too many insecurities to
really consider an open relationship
like you said dude I'm way too many
insecurities like like The Bachelorette
brought all those out I was like holy
crap dude I can't share a woman with
anyone yeah if your partner is being
intimate with someone else for that time
that they're with that person they're
not thinking of you no I'm a church
going Sunday school boys yeah the church
group thing remember there's no shots
baby
Jesse Jesse Jesse thank you sir
September 28th that's the big day huh
September 28th 9 8 central this is gonna
be a season fans are not going to want
to miss oh come on aren't you going to
say it's historic or it's the most
dramatic season ever well that's your
job I just make the drinks sit back and
let the drama come to me speaking of
that the drama really did come to you
this season have you ever seen that many
love triangles on the beach no of course
we got all those bachelorettes come down
to the beach too yeah that had the cast
on the edge of their seats and we gotta
talk about the wedding are we allowed to
talk about that's a good point actually
I probably should just let the fans see
that for themselves yeah all right don't
miss all the entertainment on Bachelor
in Paradise Thursdays 9 8 central on ABC
and stream on Hulu all right let's get
back to the show yeah I'm okay with
stepping on people's toes if it means
getting the person I'm interested in
thank you
oh Peter no one would no one would guess
this wait
oh yeah yeah that's something
that was easy you'll step on somebody's
toes I don't mind mowing all these dudes
down that line to get to the girl that I
want I would do it respectfully I would
never break a relationship off I would
never do that what I'm saying is if I
have people in front of me and I have to
get to somebody I have no problem
um no I I strongly I've been eminently
disagree I think that and at the end of
the day it's their choice if they don't
see my worth like I'm not going to step
on people's toes and do all that kind of
stuff like I'll show her what I have and
at the end of the day leave it up to her
to make the decision like you don't need
to step on people I think this question
is interpreted differently by you and I
I'm somewhat agreeing the sense of like
I believe you should go for what you
want but at the same time it was already
mentioned about being respectful about
it I wouldn't step on toes but will
would you suck on toes to get what you
want
as long as you're clean would you suck
my toes well I suck your toes they do
look good why not freshly done I might
wait
in my mind like stepping on toes is like
you're having a conversation with a girl
and I come in and say hey man I'm a
stealer and talk to her like I'm not
gonna do that like yeah that's not me I
was on that beach of paradise I was
there this summer and I don't want to
say he stepped on some toes but he
definitely stepped on some toes to get
what he wanted in my opinion my family
has to approve of the person I married
[Applause]
yeah we're here again can't keep doing
this Braden versus us thing yeah I'm
just saying though it's like when you're
in love it's a personal experience it's
internal it's not external it doesn't
come from other people's expectations of
that relationship it comes from how that
person makes you feel so if someone from
the outside says that they don't like
her and stuff like that it doesn't mean
that she doesn't make you feel good
doesn't make you feel whole I'm looking
for what I want not what my family wants
I agree and I completely I completely
agree does it take a village to raise a
family yes true true but again you get
to pick your you get to pick your
village Brandon what you said I agree
with what I'll disagree with though and
this is why I'm on the agree side my
family knows me better than anyone else
in the world we've all been there we've
been infatuated with women before you
know you have you know you've been
infatuated sometimes we get blindsided I
know I have and I needed people closest
to me who really knew who I was to show
me wow like I'm changing for someone or
I'm not is that your family or is that
your friends family and friends but the
question
I kind of agree with you on this I agree
with what you're saying Peter I grew up
with the best childhood the kid could
ever ask for but some of us weren't
fortunate enough to have a family like
mine or like yours where they had to
grow up a lot faster and become adults
at a really young age I'm standing here
for the people that didn't have a
fortunate childhood because their
opinion if they couldn't raise you
doesn't really matter exactly that's
that's the ending point on that is
exactly it depends on your relationship
with your family and that's why I
somewhat disagree like I would hope that
my family would come to like her but
like again dude it's like it's your own
personal relationship with her it's not
like it's nobody else's you know what I
mean I like
I like plays hard to get
oh
you agree I don't want nothing easy you
didn't move yeah I'm in the middle dude
obviously well you gotta stay true yeah
you have to stay wire in the middle a
woman that knows her worth is gonna show
you her interests and give you her
energy but at the same time
she's not gonna just give you all of it
right away she needs to see you put some
effort into it's 50 50 split dude I kind
of like the 50 50 split I guess I guess
I'm a little bit more 50 50.
it's a push pull bro come back to the
middle no it is it is it is but I feel
like 50 50 is a losing proposition
because like if you're expecting 50 and
like the person doesn't give you 50 like
you're a shortchanged relationship what
about just a girl playing games period
it's not a game player that's toxic but
maybe she's a little guarded you know
like she wants to like bet her husband
or like that like you know a strong
boyfriend or someone that can like
withstand the test he sings hella slow
you want to hang out with her every day
she doesn't know right I'll hang out
with you like next week or in a couple
weeks and she's like no I gotta go to
school
there is only one person that I'm meant
to be with
yeah
I I just feel like the world is so big
there's so many people out there yeah so
you feel like you have multiple soul
mates yeah yeah because it's it's time
it's place I mean she could be in a
different country that I'm never going
to visit does that mean you're meant to
be with them
ooh I firmly believe that you can like
match with multiple people yeah but like
it's true right place right time yeah
right person all right I'll buy it
that's my guy yes sir thank you Aaron
I'm still I'm still waiting to
understand so like like there's eight
billion people in the world right and
like there's only one person that's
meant for you the big ass ocean dude
there's hella fish in that ocean but
there's only one fish that that you can
eat or not eat there's only one fish
that you can be with right is that what
is that what you all are saying you have
to sift through the ocean to find your
fish and once you find it I struggle
with that though too actually so I'm
gonna take one more step because I'm
starting to think too like so say you
find your person and you know that
person like ends up passing away kind of
like in Gary situation yeah does that
mean they're not meant to be with anyone
else you're meant to be alone the rest
of your life you said earlier just that
period of time you were supposed to be
with that person during that period of
time and now that time is over it's time
for someone else the woman that you meet
that you want to start a family with you
don't just bury them and forget about
them like you always have your person in
your head yeah well that's your final
thought on it I think that at some point
you can have another person they'll
never be the same as that first person
you show so you could still love that
person they could you know become a
person that is important to you see
exactly what Gary told us he'll never
forget this person that he was married
to but he thinks he's ready again
to find something for the next chapter
one person per chapter that's what I'll
say yeah I like that all right cool
did you really think we would let the
spoilers out here watch The Bachelor in
Paradise Premiere Thursday at 9 8
central on ABC and stream on Hulu the
new season of The Bachelor in Paradise
is about to Premiere and I couldn't be
more excited honestly I'm excited for
everyone to see the love stories unfold
true raw emotions come out if you think
there's going to be a night full of no
drama you're wrong I'm looking forward
to seeing some items broken
maybe some hearts too
maybe get smacked by a wave or two
it's bananas
I went to the beach and left it all out
there and it was definitely an
experience
it was a good summer to say the least
can you tell me how you really feel
about where it is yeah I mean after this
are we done yeah yeah he's a dirt bag
can I get out
[Music]
oh dude what who's a dirtbag now babe
myself